In this class we'll build a Pitch
Perfect App which let's you record
your voice and
play it back with changes to the pitch.
This lesson is an introduction
to where we explore and
get comfortable with Xcode,
Apple's development environment.
You can use Xcode to create apps for
any of Apple's platforms.
From the watch to AppleTV To iOS and
even the Mac.
This lesson is all about
getting comfortable with Xcode.
In Lesson 2 we'll set up
the basic structure of the app,
learning how to connect UI elements,
such as buttons, to our code.
In Lesson 3 we're going to step it
up a notch, add multiple views to
the Pitch Perfect app, as well as
adding the code to record audio.
Towards the end, in lessons 4 and
5 you'll learn how to play back your
own voice with the pitch perfect app
with various alterations to the pitch.
You'll also learn how to deploy
pitch perfect on your iOS device.
As you progress this course,
we'll be introducing the Swift And
iOS concepts you need to know
in order to build pitch perfect.
After that in UIkit fundamentals will go
into much further depth in both swift,
and iOS.
Follow the links below
to download Xcode and
begin your adventure in iOS development.